back in 2012 interesting President
Barack Obama he did the same thing
congratulating Putin that now the
media's excoriating President Trump for
you cannot make this stuff up
that is how hypocritical the media the
left-wing in this country are take a
look at this Obama White House press
release release it reads in part quote
President Obama called Russian
president-elect and Prime Minister Putin
to congratulate him on his recent
victory in the Russian presidential
election that's the same thing that
Trump did where's the outrage where's
the media condemnation this is all one
big massive hypocritical double standard
that's on display and sadly we see it
every day and the media is whipping
themselves into a frenzy acting like
this is a major massive national
security crisis it's not and by the way
since the media won't tell you about the
facts as it relates to President Obama
on Russia will give them to you remember
Obama and Hillary Clinton's this
embarrassing idiotic so-called Russian
reset there she is presenting it to her
counterpart by the way it was a photo-op
and a bad one at that and it
accomplished nothing then of course you
had Obama on the hot mic whispering to
Dmitry Medvedev he said toe
Vladimir I'll have more flexibility
after the election more flexibility
Africa will show you the tape
i transmit to vladimir oh how'd that
work out for Obama now in 2014 as a
history lesson
congressman Devin newness of the house
Intel committee he issued an explicit
warning to President Obama the Russians
are coming and want to influence our
elections and the Putin wants to create
chaos in the United States and around
the world so what did Obama do
absolutely nothing instead of keeping an
eye on Russia Obama mocked then
candidate Trump in 2016
say it's ridiculous to think that anyone
could rig an election no serious person
would ever say that or believe that and
then he said stop whining remember this
there is no serious person out there who
would suggest somehow that you could
even you could even rig America's
elections in part because they're so
decentralized and the numbers of votes
involved there's no evidence that that
has happened in the past or that there
are instances in which that will happen
this time
and so I divide mr. Trump to stop whinin
and go try to make his case to get votes
you know what it doesn't get any more
pompous or arrogant than that and
according to a new book Obama's own
national security adviser Susan Rice
remember she issued the stand-down order
to national security officials that were
coming up with options do they wanted to
counter Russia's attempt at election
interference well that's just the simple
truth Obama was warned in 2014 and did
nothing said it could never happen stop
whining the media is not going to report
that